- So Sydney Powell is back in the news
for saying something incredibly crazy.
She is apparently going
around telling people
that Former President Trump
can simply be reinstated as president
and he will be president
as soon as this summer.
She said, specifically,
"This is the first case of abject fraud
"and obtaining a coup from
the United States of America,
"so it's going to have to be dealt with.
"It should be that he
can simply be reinstated,
"that a new inauguration day is set
"and Biden is told to move
out of the White House
"and President Trump should move back in."
Uh, yeah, that is not a thing.
That is not only the law, there
is no mechanism whatsoever
that that could possibly happen.
Yeah, that is just hilariously dumb.
That is not a thing.
That's not going to happen.